All right, here we are at layer number two, which is the data link layer, appropriate
name. All right, here we are at layer number two, which is the data link layer, appropriate
name for this layer, data link really means that it links the data between the two adjacent
layers that are next to it. So if you know what the layer below the data link layer is,
that's the physical layer. And then above the data link layer we have the network layer.
The data link layer allows those two adjacent layers to actually talk to each other. Because
when you look at what the network layer works with, it works with data grams and packets,
that's not what the physical layer works with. The physical layer as we've already learned can
only work with bits, zeros and ones. So the layer in between, which is this layer, guess what it
does? It takes information from the network layer as data grams and formats those as bits so that
the physical layer can work with them as bits. At the other end, guess what the data link layer
does? It takes the bits of information from the physical layer and formats them in such a way so
that the network layer can work with them as packets and data grams. So it really allows the two
adjacent layers to it to be able to talk to each other. Think of it as the translator or the
go between that allows the two adjacent layers to talk to each other. Now at this, at this layer is
also where we reference what are called your physical unique address across a network. In other
words, a network is made up of different devices that are connected to each other, but the network
needs to understand each of those devices uniquely. So there needs to be some sort of unique physical
address that the network can reference for each of the devices that are connected to each other.
This is called the MAC address. The MAC address is really a function of your network card that
allows you to connect to the network and every device connected to a network has to have a unique
physical MAC address that is referenced here at layer two. And it looks something like you see
there on your screen, but what the industry needs to make sure is that each of these MAC addresses
are unique as they come from the manufacturers. So there is a system by which this is insured.
For example, the first number of bits for your MAC address relates to the vendor.
And so that would be unique to a vendor. And then the next set of bits is something else that
ensures uniqueness and so on so that we can have network cards and devices that come from different
manufacturers. They all need to have unique physical addresses because if you didn't,
that would confuse the network every device or node connected to a network has to have a unique
physical address that is referenced here as a MAC address. Although when we get to the network
layer, you'll see that the logical addressing in networking is actually done at the network layer,
not at the data link layer, which was what we're talking about here. The data link layer simply
provides the physical unique address through the MAC address itself. Now here's where we also talk
about the two types of networks that exist because if you remember what a network is, it's a bunch
of devices that are connected to each other. Now how we communicate with other devices is the
difference between circuit switch networks and packet switch networks. Those are the two types
of networks that can exist. Now the easiest way to think of circuit switch networks is the
phone network itself, the PSTN, the public switch telephone network or what some telephone people
call the POTS, the plain old telephone system. That network has been around for over 100 years in
some cases. But what they figured out back in those days was that the best way to carry the
human voice, which is what this network has been built to do, are actually analog frequencies,
I think, between 4,000 hertz and 6,000 hertz. But this network has been built to handle analog
frequencies because that's the best way to represent your voice. But in order to be able to
communicate across this network and here's why it's called a circuit switch network, two devices
that need to communicate with each other have to actually establish a circuit or a connection between
them. Now that connection can be either physical or logical, but we need to establish a full duplex
type of connection, which means we can talk in both directions at the same time. Our animation
here I think does a pretty good job of showing what this looks like. There is a series of devices
along the way called switches across the telephone network that will ultimately establish a connection
between you and that other person that you want to talk to. And of course what you do is you dial
their number, but that activates those switches across the way that will ultimately establish
a logical or physical connection so that now we can talk back and forth in both directions.
That's what we call a full duplex type of connection. We can both talk to each other at the same
time, even though if we did that, we wouldn't understand each other, but that is possible. That's
what we call full duplex type of connection. This is what the telephone network is and in fact,
if you think of the telephone network, it is a perfect example of a circuit switch network.
The telephone network. Now, if you remember back in the old days, when data started to become
something that was really important to organizations, the only way that you could connect remotely
to your internal network was to actually use the only network that was available for us to do that.
And that was the telephone network, but the problem with the telephone network is that it has
a limitation because it is a analog technology. It was built to carry the human voice and the
best way to do that is to use analog technologies. So the only way that you could carry data across
it was to take your digital signals that computers use and turn them into analog so that they could
be carried across the analog telephone network. And then at the other end, you would have a similar
device that would take that analog signal and turn it back into digital. And of course, those devices
are called modems, aren't they? In fact, the word modem comes from modulation, demodulation,
which does exactly what we just described. It takes your digital signals, turns them into analog
so that they can be carried across the analog telephone network. And then, of course, at the other
end, we turn it back into digital. Now, there's always been a problem with this. And that is,
there's a limitation in the speeds and the bandwidth, for example, that we can host. And that is
because the analog telephone network is analog. It's backbone is analog. And so we've always had
that limitation, which I think is 56,000 bits per second. And a lot of people ask a question,
why haven't we improved modem technology to give us faster speeds? Well, we have, in fact,
in fact, all of you probably use DSL modems and cable modems that handle much faster speeds.
But the problem with the telephone network is not in the modem. It's in the network itself.
That's why we still have that limitation with modems. So obviously, when data started to
become a requirement, we couldn't use modems anymore because of that limitation. So that forced
companies to build separate and specific data networks to handle the quantity of data, the speeds
that we required today. And those are called packet switched networks. So the easiest way to think
of this is that all data networks are packet switched. The way this works is if we need to send
information between devices, we're not going to establish a circuit or connection first.
What I do if I need to send you information as I take that information and I break it up into
manageable chunks. And then I individually address each of those chunks. And then I send them along
the way. Now those chunks, called packets or datagrams typically, will travel in different directions.
You know, they may arrive in a different order than they were sent. Some of them may not even arrive.
But you know, basically we have the technology to be able to do that, receive those datagrams and packets
and reconstruct them into what the original data look like. That's what all data networks do.
And because we break things up into manageable chunks that can be each individually addressed
and sent along the way, these are called packet switch networks. All data networks work this way.
All data networks are packet switch networks because they can handle the high volumes and bandwidths
and speeds that we need today for the applications that really data networks are built for today.
Here's just a basic summary of the two types of networks that can exist. And pretty
intuitively you can see the difference here and what they're typically used for. Just remember
that circuit switched is the voice network. All data networks are packet switch because they
can give us the speeds and the bandwidth and what we need today for our applications.
Now across data networks though, sometimes you may want connections that are established on demand
or for example, maybe companies need to link, you know, a data network in one location to a data
network in another location permanently. Let's say we are a company that has offices in two
different cities. And so we may want to link those two offices or data networks together permanently.
That's what we call permanent virtual circuits. Those are data network connections that are
established typically across what we call wide area network technologies that are offered to us
by our providers. We'll talk more about that later on. Whereas a switched virtual circuit is one
that we establish on demand. And then once we're finished, we tear it down. Perfect example of that
would be a VPN connection. So that's the difference between the two types of connections that we can
establish across data networks or packet switch networks.